the decorous independence says something
that you don't really find in the
ancient world it says all men are
created equal and yet they are so
obviously different aren't they in
America we like sports and in sports
they keep score and you find out whose
equal and who's not and you find it out
release what does equality mean then in
what way or respect is it true that all
men are created equal
what does it mean equal but what does it
mean all men are created equal win
obviously by the way they are not like
you look around the table I'm old you're
young boys and girls large and small
younger and older you're just a baby
aren't you yes precocious sophomore is
old Christian here so so we're not equal
right what does it men all men are
created equal what do they mean
equal dignity as human beings even
though they might be endowed with
different degrees so Hitler and
Churchill for example have equal dignity
yes yeah I wonder what does dignity mean
it it references the nature of man as
having a right to exist in some respect
at least insofar as being in like the
body that you are mm-hmm okay
compare children and dogs the most
important comparison by the way in the
entire academic world key to
understanding all nature is to compare
children and dogs I don't like cats
I don't but children and dogs right and
what is it about the children and the
dogs you can raise them just about the
same way when they're young but then
some point the children start speaking
and somehow they've picked up on how
people act and how people interact they
talk
yeah the specific thing they do see in
my family the children
grown now and we had these two boxers
and they're really great one of them's a
three-legged dog and he's the happiest
dog we ever had and the dogs are
everywhere wherever we are so you guys
are all coming over to my house for
dinner and you will find that you'll be
dining with the dogs and when we were
raising the kids the dogs were always
there and after about a year and a half
the kids started talking and the dogs
never did and they they'd all heard
exactly the same things right so this
talking Aristotle says that the gift of
speech which is identical he claims to
reason or rationality they are the same
thing the argument is when you are
talking you are thinking to yourself you
are thinking out loud and when you are
thinking you are talking to yourself
it's the same thing now somehow this
capacity we have that makes us human
there's some respect in which we are all
created equal and where I think that is
is this phenomenon of the dogs and the
kids dogs at various times in their
lives are greatly preferable to children
right but they're not the same kind of
thing else they would say so and they
never do right last night the dogs were
talking to us as dogs talking right and
Aristotle says animals use their voices
to indicate pleasure and pain people
speak to distinguish the just from the
unjust right this whole thing is a
statement of the just and the unjust and
it depends on this simple point this is
what all men are created equal means you
are the King of England and you ride in
a golden carriage and everybody salutes
you and all fear you but you know when
you were a year-and-a-half old you
started doing something that no animal
has ever
done and no one taught you to do that
you just started doing it and it wasn't
because you were born royal it's because
you were born human and so were we
it just means that and they think what
that allows our kids like to say cow
they have an English mother they English
say that word very well but it's just a
sound right cow cow cow why not plop
flat whack you know why not a million
things are a cow cow what's that got to
do with that thing out in the field
everyone different from everyone else
right and they can just look at a
two-dimensional picture of a cow and
identify it and then you can take it out
in the field and show them a bunch of
animals and they'll point out what you
wants the cow but that means before they
can they're old enough to even go
outside by themselves their whole
universe gets populated by all of the
things that it's in ours planets stars
worms bees everything they can get all
of that right and they can get all that
by the time they're three years old and
then by the time they're five years old
for sure they can start identifying the
sounds they make with marks on a page
and then they're reading and then the
next thing you know they're reading
Shakespeare and then they can do numbers
because numbers are just the same kind
of symbols except for quantities and
once you can do the basic math you're on
your way to quantum mechanics every
human being can do that every single one
and no other creature has ever done that
and born in this gift you see that we
can speak and therefore see that thing
and that thing is the same kind of thing
and it doesn't make any difference if
it's your kid or somebody else's you
can't treat it like a dog because it is
not a dog and no king can treat it like
a
because it is not a dog to him either
because it's not a dog see once the
ground is laid for that then of course
Thomas Jefferson can write in the last
serious letter he wrote some are not
born with saddles on their backs nor
others booted and spurred to ride them
by the grace of God the King can rightly
put a harness on the horses that pull
his carriage but he can't do that to
people unless they volunteer you see
that's a tremendous philosophic
proposition and the ultimate source of
human freedom and this by the way is the
greatest political statement of that in
all history
you
[Music]